resulta que no solo un campo magnético
ejerce una fuerza sobre una carga en
movimiento o bien sobre una corriente
sino que también las cargas en
movimiento y las corrientes inducen un
campo magnético esto está padre porque
nos da una cierta simetría entre estos
dos conceptos y después eso es una pista
para que con cálculo y otras
herramientas más avanzadas podamos ver
que los campos magnéticos y eléctricos
son dos lados de una misma moneda de los
campos electromagnéticos bueno por el
momento vamos a enfocarnos en esto de
que una carga en una corriente crean un
campo magnético de hecho tan solo un
electrón crea un campo magnético pero
bueno eso tiene sus detallitos vamos a
pensar mejor aún escalo un poco más
grande y para esto vamos a dibujar un
ala nueva entonces ese de ahí es un
alambre y vamos a pensar que por ese
alambre está pasando una corriente y
déjame ponerla
y la voy a poner así que va hacia arriba
vale entonces por aquí está pasando una
corriente
bueno resulta que aquí se genera un
campo magnético y la forma es la
siguiente la forma del campo es que hace
círculos concéntricos alrededor del
alambre en cierta dirección
ahorita la voy a pintar con este color
rojo resulta que se crean círculos
concéntricos en esta dirección
vale entonces esa es una forma de
describirlo pero otra forma de
describirlo así con la anotación que
hemos usado antes es poner que del lado
derecho el campo magnético entra
observa la flecha está entrando y luego
pasa por atrás entonces aquí entra esto
de aquí son las colas de las flechas
pero luego al darle la vuelta al alambre
y pasar del lado izquierdo al chocar
aquí con el plano de la pantalla tenemos
que el campo magnético sale estos de
aquí son las puntas de las flechas que
están mostrando que el campo sale ahora
como se supone que es esto o sea como
como se que se ve así bueno pues resulta
que hay una cierta fórmula que usa un
producto cruz pero es mejor pensar en
estas reglas que nos simplifican la vida
y aquí vamos a utilizar otra regla de la
mano derecha y ésta tiene que ver con
agarrar el alambre déjame tomar este
color para dibujar una mano y entonces
lo que uno hace es pensar que agarra
este alambre con la mano derecha
poniendo el pulgar en dirección en
dirección de la corriente entonces nos
quedaría algo así este sería mi mi
pulgar por este lado irían mis dedos por
aquí viene el índice
tenemos el resto de la mano y por acá
baja la muñeca sale entonces al poner al
poner la mano así lo que sucede es que
el pulgar va en dirección de la
corriente y los dedos bueno déjame dar
aquí el alambre tonces aquí está el
alambre que lo estamos agarrando
pero los dedos justo giran en el sentido
que tiene que ir el campo magnético back
mira es lo mismo que acá y que acá
arriba y los dedos están saliendo de
este lado del alambre que es justo lo
que marcan estos puntitos o bien esta
flecha back entonces así es como nos
acordamos hacia dónde tiene que girar
bueno vamos a seguir agarrando un
poquito de intuición acerca de esto y
pensemos qué sucede si estamos cerca del
alambre pues la intuición nos debería
decir que mientras más cerca estemos
pues el campo magnético va a ser más
fuerte va a tener una mayor magnitud y
esto tiene sentido porque si nos
alejamos y nos alejamos pues como que
ese campo magnético se va repartiendo en
un área más grande aquí tenemos un
pequeño círculo entonces se reparte un
poquito pero por acá por acá ya tenemos
un círculo grandote entonces el campo
queda repartido en una pues en una mayor
porción y por eso va a ser menor ahorita
que pongan la fórmula vas a ver cómo
refleja esta idea para entonces ya
tenemos cómo se ve ya tenemos la forma o
bien la dirección así que ya nada más no
voy a preocupar por la magnitud y la voy
a poner con este color azul
bueno resulta que el campo magnético
tiene la siguiente magnitud está dada
por un hábitat voy a decir que se está
muy es una letra griega que parece como
una u multiplicado por la corriente
dividido
dividido entre dos por pi por r y quién
es este r pues es lo que platicábamos es
la distancia a la cual estamos del
alambre entonces pensemos que es esta
distancia de acá vale estoy acá es r
bueno entonces esto de aquí es la
formulita hasta ahorita no he probado
nada pero más o menos tiene sentido con
lo que hemos platicado si eres muy
grande la magnitud se hace pequeña si
estamos a una misma distancia y debería
de ser pues la misma magnitud que esta
idea de los círculos para vamos a
platicar de esta muy está muy se le
conoce como la permeabilidad del
material o del ambiente y eso tiene que
ver con en donde está el alambre si el
alambre está no sé en hule o en agua o
en metal o en aire o en el vacío
entonces este mundo tiene que ver con el
ambiente van o no con el material del
cable sino con dónde está para la física
de prepa de preparatoria pues usualmente
el ambiente es aire y resulta que la
permeabilidad del aire es muy similar a
la permeabilidad del vacío son casi
iguales entonces
pues usualmente cuando cuando decimos
que está en el aire utilizamos la
permeabilidad del vacío a la cual le
llamamos muy 0 va entonces estar acá es
la del vacío está de acá es una
constante son ciertos numeritos que pues
yo no me he aprendido pero como siempre
no se puede almacenar en la calculadora
o buscarla en internet o en una tabla ok
entonces ahora sí vamos a hacer un
problema para entender todas estas ideas
y nada más hay que ponerles numeritos
pensemos que esta corriente es de 2
samper o amperes pensemos que este punto
está a 3 metros de distancia a 3 metros
de distancia del alambre de acá
y entonces con esta información ya
podemos ver pues qué sucede con el campo
magnético ya sabemos cuál es la
dirección porque como estamos acá del
lado izquierdo sabemos que el campo
magnético está saliendo y por lo tanto
la dirección del campo es hacia afuera
de la pantalla
vamos con la magnitud y para eso nada
más hay que substituir acá entonces que
nos quedaría nos quedaría que ve la
magnitud la magnitud debe el campo
magnético es igual a estamos suponiendo
vamos a suponer que estamos en el aire
entonces usaremos la permeabilidad del
vacío ahorita vemos cuánto es x y que
sabemos que estos amperes además le voy
a poner el 2 dividido
dividido entre dos por pin dos volví por
r por tres hay que asegurarnos que todo
esté en el sistema internacional pero si
verdad
pérez metros y la permeabilidad si todo
está en sistema internacional esto de
aquí cuánto es pues antes de pasarle a
la calculadora simplificamos el 2 con el
2 nos queda muy 0 dividido entre 3 y 10
dividido entre 3 pi muy bien entonces
vamos a la calculadora a ver qué nos
dice
entonces voy a pasarla para acá
venciendo este valor de la permeabilidad
lo guardé aquí en esta variable
porque se parece a mí
entonces vamos a ver cuánto nos da
dividido entre tres por ti
3 por ti otra vez está aún la uar de
ello previamente en la calculadora pero
la puedes buscar en internet o en una
tabla entonces eso nos da 1.33 por 10 a
la menos 7 entonces la magnitud
de 1.33 por 10 a la menos 7 y como el
campo magnético son teclas esta de aquí
presencialidad es una magnitud muy muy
pequeña es 10 a la menos 7 es un campo
magnético bien débil y bueno por esta
razón los cables de tu televisión no
andan alborotando las monedas pero bueno
porque hay entonces fíjate todo está muy
padre verdad con esto ya vimos que no
sólo los campos magnéticos mueven a las
partículas cargadas o bien afectan a las
corrientes que pasan por un alambre sino
que además la corriente que pasa por un
alambre crea un campo magnético que
tiene una forma circular esto está padre
como te decía al principio eso nos da
una cierta simetría también pasa esto en
electrostática donde las cargas y los
campos eléctricos están muy relacionados
entre sí de hecho si sigues estudiando
física cada vez más avanzada vas a poder
ver esto que te digo de que los campos
electro
eléctricos y los magnéticos son dos
lados de una misma moneda van más o
menos tiene que ver con que se ve
magnético si es un campo que está
pasando a tu lado pero si te mueves
junto al campo entonces parece ser
estático y entonces se parece un poco
más a un campo eléctrico
bueno lo voy a dejar aquí y si quieres
puedes investigar más al respecto pero
en el siguiente vídeo veremos qué sucede
si tenemos dos alambres paralelos por
los cuales está pasando una carga y
vamos a ver si esos alambres se atraen o
bien se repelen